- People should think, well,
"I feel fear about this,
"and therefore I shouldn't do it."
It's normal to feel fear.
Like, there'd have to
be definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fear.
And there's a friend
of mine who says, like,
"Starting a company is like staring
"into the abyss and eating glass,"
and there's some truth to that.
And a successful company
is very much more about,
"How quick are you to fix the mistakes?"
Not, "Will you make mistakes?"
The one thing I couldn't
compress was the cost of launch
'cause there were only a few options,
and the US options were way too expensive,
so I ended up going to Russia three times
to try to buy the biggest ICBM
in the Russian nuclear fleet.
- He's the CEO of SpaceX and Tesla Motors,
and the chairman of Solar City.
His goals of starting these businesses
always revolve around changing
the world and humanity.
He has an estimated net worth
of 11.5 billion dollars.
He's Elon Musk, and here's my take on his
top 10 rules to success, part two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Elon's talking,
if he says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- You are unusually
fearless and willing to go
in the face of other people
telling you something is crazy,
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people.
You still stand out.
Where does that come from,
or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells you,
"This is a crazy idea," or where do you
get the internal strength to do that?
- Well, first of all,
I'd say I actually think
I feel fear quite strongly,
so it's not as though
I just have the absence of fear.
I feel it quite strongly.
But there are just times when something is
important enough, that
you believe in it enough,
that you do it in spite of fear.
- So, speaking of important things--
- Like, people shouldn't think,
"Well, I feel fear about this,
"and therefore I shouldn't do it."
It's normal to feel fear.
Like, you'd have to
definitely have something
mentally wrong with you
if you didn't feel fear.
- So, you just feel it,
and let the importance
of it drive you to do it anyway?
- Yeah.
You know, actually, something that
can be helpful is
fatalism, at some degree.
If you just accept the probabilities,
then that diminishes fear,
so when starting SpaceX,
I thought the odds of
success were less than 10%,
and I just accepted
that actually, probably,
I would just lose everything,
but that maybe, we
would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward.
Even if we died, maybe some other company
could pick up the baton
and keep moving it forward,
so that would still do some good.
Yeah, same with Tesla.
I thought, you know, odds of a car company
succeeding were extremely low.
I would definitely advise people
who are starting a company
to expect a long period
of quite high difficulty.
- Yeah.
- But, I mean, as long as
people stay super-focused
on creating the absolute
best product to service
that really delights their end customer.
If they stay focused on
that, then basically,
if you get it such that your
customers want you to succeed,
then you probably will.
- All right.
You have to focus on the
customer and delivering for them.
- Yeah.
Make sure, if your customers love you,
your odds of success of
are dramatically higher.
One does have to be
focused on the short-term
and money coming in
when creating a company,
because otherwise, the company will die,
so a lot of the times, people will think,
like, creating a company
is going to be fun.
I would say it's really not that fun.
I mean, there are periods of fun,
and there are periods
where it's just awful.
And particularly, if
you're CEO of the company,
you actually have a distillation
of all the worst problems in a company.
See, there's no point
in spending your time
on things that are going
right, so you're only
spending your time on
things that are going wrong,
and there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't take care of,
so you have, like, the worst.
You have a filter for the
crappest problems in the company.
(laughs)
The most pernicious and painful problems.
So I wouldn't say it's,
I think you have to feel
quite compelled to do it
and have a fairly high
pain threshold, and
there's a friend of mine
who says, like, "Starting
a company is like
"staring into the abyss and eating glass."
And there's some truth to that.
(audience laughing)
The staring into the abyss
part is that you're going to be
constantly facing the
extermination of the company,
'cause most start-ups fail.
Like, 99% of start-ups fail.
So, that's the staring
into the abyss part.
You're constantly saying, "Okay,
"if I don't get this right,
the company will die."
Should be quite stressful.
And then, the eating glass part is,
you've got to work on the
problems that the company
needs you to work on, not the
problems you want to work on,
and so you end up working on problems
that you'll really wish
you weren't working on,
and so that's the eating glass part.
And that goes on for a long time.
- [Audience Member] So,
how do you keep your focus
on the big picture when
you're constantly faced with,
"We could be out of business in a month?"
- Well, it's just a very small percentage
of mental energy that's
on the big picture.
Like, you know where you're
generally heading for,
and the actual path is
going to be some sort of
zig-zaggy thing in that direction.
You're trying not to deviate
too far from the path
that you want to be
on, but you're going to
have to do that to some degree.
But I don't want to diminish the,
I mean, I think the profit
motive is a good one
if the rules of an industry
are properly set up.
So there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with profit.
In fact, profit just means
that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing than
you're spending to create it.
That's a good thing.
(laughs)
And if that's the not the case,
then you'll be out of
business, and rightfully so.
'Cause you're not adding enough value.
First of all, I really need
to give some thought to, like,
how can I provide advice
that would be most helpful,
and I'm not sure I've given
enough thought to that
to give you the best possible answer,
but I think, certainly,
being focused on something
that you're confident will have
high value to someone else,
and just being really rigorous
in making that assessment,
because people tend to,
a natural human tendency
is wishful thinking, so a
challenge for entrepreneurs
is to say, "Well, what's
the difference between
"really believing in your
ideals and sticking to them
"versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
"that doesn't actually have merit?"
And that is a really difficult thing to,
can you tell the difference
between those two things.
So, you need to be sort of
very rigorous in your self-analysis.
Certainly extremely tenacious,
and then just work like hell.
I mean, you just have to put in, you know,
80 to 100 hour weeks every week.
- That is a lot of work.
- All those things improve
the odds of success.
If other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks
and you're putting in 100 hour work weeks,
then even if you're doing the same thing,
you know that in one
year, you will achieve in
four months what it takes
them a year to achieve.
- So failures are not
the most terrible things.
You have to learn from it and react to it.
- Yeah, exactly.
When you're building something new,
there's going to be mistakes,
and it's important to
recognize those mistakes,
acknowledge them,
and take corrective action.
And the success of a company
is very much more about
"How quick are you to fix the mistakes?"
Not, "Will you make mistakes?"
- Or admit the mistakes.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And if you see the difference between
a start-up that is successful
and one that is not,
it is because the successful one,
they're both made of mistakes,
but the successful one
recognized the mistakes,
fixed them very quickly,
and the unsuccessful one
tries to deny that the mistakes exist.
- You know, extremely smart people
are sometimes quite arrogant,
because they believe in
what they believe in, right,
and so when they face criticism,
it's less likely to admit
they can make mistakes.
Was that in your case?
- I learnt it when I was studying physics.
In physics, you're taught
to always question yourself,
you're taught to always
assume that you're wrong,
not to assume that you're
right, and you have to prove
yourself not wrong, and so I
think that physics framework
is really where I learnt
it, and it's very effective
for learning counter-intuitive
things that aren't obvious.
- Mm.
So, you are very famous
in saying that failure
is actually an option,
and if you're not failing
that means you're not innovative enough.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's not like I like failure.
I mean, who likes failure?
But if you only do things
that are certain to succeed,
then you're only going to be
doing very obvious things.
- A question that has been discussed
over the past couple of days.
Should we be considering
one-way only trips to Mars?
What's the best approach
to colonize the planet?
Is it, well, what's your view?
Is that socially acceptable?
You think people will sign up to do it?
- I think there's plenty of people
that would sign up for
a one-way trip to Mars.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe if I could have a show of hands.
Who would consider such an option?
(audience chattering and laughing)
I see some.
Not many, but perhaps enough
for a couple of missions.
(audience laughing)
- Certainly be enough.
I think it's sort of, like, is it a
one-way mission and then you die,
or is it a one-way mission
and you get resupplied?
There's a big difference.
(laughs)
- We're for the second option.
- Yeah, exactly.
But I think it ends up being a moot point,
because you want to
bring the spaceship back.
Like, these spaceships
are expensive, okay?
They're hard to build.
You can't just leave them there.
So whether or not people
want to come back or not
is kind of, like, they
can jump on if they want,
but we need the spaceship back.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- Thank you.
- I mean, it'd be kind of
weird if there was, like,
this huge collection of
spaceships on Mars all the time,
like, we would send them back.
I mean, of course we would send them back.
- Now, with Tesla, your goal
has been to make a better car,
and you've done that
with an electric vehicle
that people covet, that
has quite a cult following,
that's upgradeable, but
you also want to achieve,
and your turn of phrase is very nice,
or try to achieve this "platonic
ideal of a car," right?
To reach for perfection.
So, what does the perfect car look like?
- Well, I mean, I do use that phrase
with our engineering and science team,
that aspirationally,
we're in pursuit of the
platonic ideal of the perfect car,
and who knows what that
looks like actually,
but you want to try to make
every element of the car
as flawless as possible,
and there'll always be
some degree of imperfection,
but try to minimize that
and create a car that is
just delightful in every way,
and I think if you do that, then the rest
kind of takes care of itself.
- You know, being innovative
can be a very exciting life,
but doing business sometimes
requires, you know,
persistence, and sometimes
could be very boring.
Do you have the fun from innovation
as from business, running a business?
Or would you rather to
be just an innovator,
engineer, instead of a
business owner or runner.
- I mean, I'd love to just
do innovation and just do
engineering, but you raise a good point,
because, you know, a lot of
life, in general, any job,
there is, like, you
have to do your chores.
You know?
- 'Cause nobody else can do that for you.
- Well, yeah.
I think to be successful
at almost anything,
you have to do the tough stuff
as well as the enjoyable stuff.
You have to do the boring stuff
as well as the non-boring stuff.
And if you don't do your chores,
then bad things will happen.
But if they don't do the things
that they don't like to do,
then the company will be in trouble.
Like, you're basically, like,
it's more fun to cook the meal
than to clean the dishes, but
you need to clean the dishes.
(laughs)
- You need to do both.
- Yes, you need to do both.
Exactly.
2001, I was just talking
to a friend of mine,
and he asked me what I was
going to do after PayPal,
and I thought, well, you
know, I was wondering,
I'd like to get involved in space,
but I just didn't think
there was anything I could do
as an individual, but I
was curious as to when
NASA would be sending a team to Mars,
because that was always
going to be the thing to do
after the moon, and I figured
that there'd be some plan
and I'd just to the website,
and I could read the schedule.
(laughing)
Oh, yeah, it's like,
"Okay, 2017, good, okay."
But actually, there wasn't
anything on the website,
or at least, I thought,
like, can I not find it?
Like, what's going on here?
Is it secret?
I don't know.
But it turned out that
NASA had done a study
on what it would cost to
do a man to Mars mission,
and this was under Bush the first,
and in his first year, he
asked for a 90-day study
shortly after taking office,
and NASA came back with
a 500 billion dollar
price tag, and he said,
"Okay, maybe not."
That's when 500 billion
dollars was serious money.
(audience laughing)
You know, for the government.
So then, that got totally shelved,
and it was, like, you are
not allowed to talk about
any kind of crewed
mission to Mars at NASA,
and anyways, so I thought,
"Well, if I could do something
"that would galvanize public interest,
"and then that public
interest would translate to
"additional appropriations for
NASA, increase their budget,
"then maybe they could
do it," so actually,
what I was sort of thinking I would do
is send a small greenhouse
to the surface of Mars
with seeds and dehydrated
gel, and then, upon landing,
hydrate the gel, grow the plants,
and the public tends to
respond to precedence
and superlative, so this
would be the furthest
that life's ever traveled,
the first life on Mars.
I was trying to figure out how to do this
with the proceeds that I had from PayPal,
and I was able to figure out
how to get the cost of the
spacecraft down and the
communications and the
little greenhouse and
everything, but the one thing
I couldn't compress
was the cost to launch.
There was only a few options,
and the US options were way too expensive,
and so I ended up going
to Russia three times
to try to buy the biggest ICBM
in the Russian nuclear fleet.
- [Interviewer] That's
where I'd start, you know?
Go big or go home, right?
- I mean, okay.
There were some strange
trips, that's for sure.
But it was, like, virtually,
like, you can buy any,
it's a very capitalist
society in some ways.
So I actually did negotiate a deal to buy
two of the ICBMs, minus the nukes.
But I came to the conclusion
after that third trip
that it wouldn't really matter.
I actually came to the conclusion that my
initial premise was wrong,
because I actually think
there's a tremendous amount of will
in the American population,
particularly to explore.
United States, you know, maybe
more than any other country
is a distillation of the
human spirit of exploration,
and it's really fundamental to the psyche,
so if people think there's a way,
I think you could actually
get a lot of support.
But it can't just be banging
your head against a wall.
You got to believe that this can be done
without breaking the federal budget,
so that's when I said, "Okay,
well, is there some way
"to affect the cost of space transport,"
and so I got together
with a group of people
over a series of Saturdays
just to try to say,
"Is there something
fundamentally super-expensive
"about rockets, or can the cost
be substantially improved?"
And we had a bunch of those
kind of brainstorming sessions,
and I couldn't see any
fundamental obstacle
to improving the cost of the rockets,
so that's when I started SpaceX.
- Said, "I'll just build it myself."
- But I'd say, definitely at that point,
the probablity of success
was definitely less than 50%.
I thought it would most
likely not succeed.
But it was worth a try.
- You're the CEO of SpaceX,
and you've said that
your ultimate goal is to
get humankind to Mars.
I've heard your response to the question,
but these guys need to hear it.
Why is Mars important?
Why does Mars matter?
- Sure, well, I think,
it's really a fundamental
decision we need to
make as a civilization.
What kind of future do we want?
Do we want a future where
we are forever confined
to one planet, until some
eventual extinction event,
however far in the
future that might occur,
or do we want to become
a multi-planet species
and then, ultimately, be
out there among the stars,
and be among many planets,
many star systems?
And I think the latter
is a far more exciting
and inspiring future than the former.
And Mars is the next natural step.
In fact, it's the only
planet we really have a shot
at establishing a self-sustaining city on,
and I think once we do
establish such a city,
there will be a strong forcing function
for the improvement of
space flight technology
that will then enable
us to establish colonies
elsewhere in the solar
system, and ultimately
extend beyond our solar system.
And so, there's the defensive
reason of protecting
the future of humanity and
ensuring that the light
of consciousness is not extinguished
should some calamity befall Earth,
but also, and that's the defensive reason,
but personally, I find that
what gets me more excited
is the fact that this would
be an incredible adventure.
I mean, it'd be, like, the
greatest adventure ever.
It would be exciting and inspiring,
and there need to be things
that excite and inspire people.
You know, after your reasons
why you get up in the morning,
it can't just be solving
problems, it's got to be,
"Yeah, something great's going
to happen in the future."
- [Host] Yeah, we talked about
this at length yesterday.
It's not an exit strategy or
a back-up plan for humankind
when Earth fails, it's also
to inspire people on Earth,
and to transcend, to go
beyond our mental limits
of what we think we can achieve.
- All right, I mean, think of, sort of,
how incredible the Apollo program was,
and just, if you ask anyone and say,
"Name some of humanity's
greatest achievements
"of the 20th century," the Apollo program,
landing on the moon, in many
places, would be number one.
- Thank you guys so much for watching
the part two series of
something that we're still
experimenting with and
having some fun with,
so let me know what you think,
if we should continue it,
if there's someone else you want
to see a part two version of.
Leave your thoughts in the comments below
and we'll see what we can do.
Also, I'm really curious to figure out
what did you learn most
from Elon in this video?
What message hit home
the hardest that you're
going to immediately apply to
your life or business somehow?
Leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout-out
to Kalie and Bradley.
Thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking that picture.
It's awesome, and I really,
really appreciate it.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- But you have also said, in terms of
where you want to go, that developing
a high-performance sports car
is not what this is about.
- Absolutely, yes.
- [Interviewer] This is
about something else,
and you want to develop a sedan.
- Yeah, the whole purpose behind Tesla,
the reason I put so much
of my time and money
into helping create the business is
we want to serve as a
catalyst for accelerating
the electric car revolution.
The price of gas at the
pump does not reflect
the true cost of gasoline,
because you have a
consumption of a public good.
It's really a common problem in economics.
You have the same thing in fishing,
where because there's no
cost to fishing stocks,
people just overfish and you
have disaster that ensues,
and here, we're not paying for the cost
of the CO2 concentrations in the oceans,
the atmospheres, we're not
paying for all the auxiliary
effects, the wars and the
other things at the gas pumps,
so you effectively have
a subsidy taking place
at the gas pump because of that.
So the only way to bridge
that is with innovation,
is to try to make electric cars better
sooner than they would otherwise be.